a human being is a part of the whole
called by us
a part limited in time and space
he experiences himself
his thoughts and feelings
as something separated from the rest
a kind of optical delusion of his
consciousness
this delusion is a kind of prison for us
restricting us to our personal desires
into affection for a few persons nearest
to us
our task must be to free ourselves from
this prison
by widening our circle of compassion to
embrace all living creatures and the
whole of nature in its beauty
nobody is able to achieve this
completely
but the striving for such achievement is
in itself
a part of the liberation
and a foundation for inner security
do
you